this cosmic calendar compresses all of
the last 13.8 billion years since the
Big Bang into a single calendar earthier
every month is a little more than a
billion years every day a little less
than 40 million a single hour is almost
2 million years that first day of the
cosmic year began with the Big Bang
almost 14 billion years ago nothing
really happened in our neck of the
universe until about 3 billion years
later March 15th when our Milky Way
galaxy began to form 6 billion years
after that power star the Sun was born
it was August 31st on the cosmic
calendar
Jupiter and the other planets including
our own would soon follow the atmosphere
on earth was a toxic environment for our
kind of life then September 21st on the
cosmic calendar tiny creatures that
could shove off the methane and eat
carbon dioxide and sunlight for
breakfast found a way to make a living
in the ocean by gobbling up the carbon
dioxide and giving off oxygen they
turned the sky blue and then the
oxygenation of the atmosphere created
the ozone layer for the first time life
was free to leave the oceans for the
land now life could grow larger and
venture forth into New Territories
sometime on December 26th about 200
million years ago the first mammals
evolved they brought a new feature to
life on earth the neocortex
and then late on New Year's Eve a
mutation occurred in the DNA of just one
of our ancestors one base pair of a
single gene programmed the neocortex to
grow larger still maybe it was a random
zap from a cosmic ray or simple error in
transmission from one cell to another
whatever it was it led to a change in
our species that ultimately affect every
other species of life on earth by the
last second of the cosmic year there was
no place on earth
that we had left untouched all of it
comes down to nothing more than a single
run on our tiny DNA ladder to the stars
[Music]